pero nunca los llevé a la escuela.
Instintivamente, sabía que los cómics no pertenecían al aula.
Mis padres definitivamente no eran fanáticos,
y estaba seguro de que mis profesores tampoco lo serían.
Después de todo, nunca los usarían para enseñar,
los cómics y novelas gráficas nunca eran permitidos en una lectura silenciosa
y nunca fueron vendidos en nuestra feria anual del libro.
A pesar de ello, seguí leyendo cómics,
incluso comencé a crearlos.
Finalmente me convertí en un caricaturista,
escribiendo y dibujando libros de cómics para vivir.
También me convertí en profesor de secundaria.
Aquí es donde enseñé:
Secundaria Bishop O'Dowd en Oakland, California.
Enseñé un poco de matemáticas y un poco de arte,
pero más que todo computación
y estuve allí por 17 años.
Cuando era un flamante profesor nuevo
traté de usar los libros de cómics dentro de mi clase.
Recuerdo decirles a mis estudiantes en el primer día de cada clase
que también era caricaturista.
No era tanto que estaba planeando enseñarles con cómics,
pero más porque esperaba que los cómics les harían pensar que era genial.
(Risas)
Estaba equivocado.
Esto era en los 90,
así que los libros de cómics no tenían el caché cultural que tienen ahora.
Mis estudiantes no creían que era genial, pensaban que era un poco tonto.
Y peor aún, cuando las cosas se ponían difíciles en mi clase,
usaban los libros de cómics como una forma de distraerme.
Levantaban sus manos y hacían preguntas como,
"Sr. Yang, ¿quién cree que ganaría en una pelea,
Superman o Hulk?"
(Risas)
Rápidamente me di cuenta de que debía separar mi enseñanza y mis caricaturas.
Parecía que mis instintos en quinto grado eran correctos.
Los libros de cómics no pertenecían al aula.
Pero de nuevo, estaba errado.
Luego de unos años en mi carrera como profesor
aprendí de primera mano el potencial educativo de los cómics.
Un semestre, me pidieron sustituir en una clase de Álgebra 2.
Me pidieron que sustituyera a largo plazo, y dije que sí, pero había un problema.
En ese tiempo también era el tecnólogo de la escuela,
por lo que cada par de semanas
tenía que perder uno o dos períodos de esta clase de Álgebra 2
porque estaba en otra clase ayudando a otro profesor
con una actividad ligada a las computadoras.
Para los estudiantes de Álgebra 2 esto era terrible.
Una sustitución a largo plazo ya era terrible,
pero tener un suplente para el profesor sustituto era peor.
En un esfuerzo de dar un poco de consistencia a mis estudiantes,
comencé a grabarme dando mis clases.
Luego le daba los vídeos a mi suplente para que los mostrara a mis estudiantes.
Traté de hacer estos vídeos lo más atractivos posible.
Hasta incluí algunos efectos especiales.
Por ejemplo, después de terminar un problema en la pizarra,
aplaudía con mis manos,
y la pizarra automáticamente se borraba.
(Risas)
Para mí era realmente increíble.
Estaba muy seguro de que a mis estudiantes les encantaría,
pero me equivoqué.
(Risas)
Las lecciones en vídeos fueron un desastre.
Los estudiantes se acercaban y me decían cosas como:
"Sr. Yang, pensábamos que era aburrido en persona,
pero en vídeo es simplemente insoportable".
(Risas)
Así que como segundo intento desesperado dibujé las lecciones como cómics.
Los hacía muy rápido y con muy poca planificación.
Tomaba un marcador y dibujaba una viñeta tras otra,
pensando qué quería decir mientras avanzaba.
Estas lecciones en forma de cómics saldrían de cuatro a seis páginas,
las copiaba y se las daba a mi suplente para que las entregara a mis estudiantes.
Y para mi gran sorpresa,
esta lecciones fueron un éxito.
Mis estudiantes me pedían que las hiciera para ellos,
inclusive cuando estaba allí en persona.
Era como si yo les gustara más en forma de caricatura que en persona.
(Risas)
Esto me sorprendió porque mis estudiantes
son parte de una generación criada con pantallas,
por eso que pensé que de seguro querrían aprender más de una pantalla
que de un papel.
Pero cuando hablé con mis estudiantes
sobre la razón por la que les gustaban tanto estas lecciones en cómics,
comencé a entender su potencial educativo.
Primero, a diferencia de sus libros de matemáticas,
estas lecciones en cómics enseñan visualmente.
Nuestros estudiantes crecen en una cultura visual
y están acostumbrados a recibir la información de esa forma.
Pero a diferencia de otras narrativas visuales,
como las películas, la televisión, las animaciones o los vídeos,
los cómics son permanentes.
En un cómic, el pasado, el presente y el futuro
están todos uno al lado del otro en la misma página.
Esto significa que la tasa de flujo de información
está firmemente en las manos del lector.
Cuando mis estudiantes no entendían algo en mis lecciones en cómics,
simplemente podían releer ese pasaje tan rápida o lentamente como necesitaran.
Era como si les estuviera dando un control remoto sobre la información.
Tampoco ocurría con mis lecciones en vídeo o en mis clases en vivo.
Cuando hablo, entrego la información tan rápida o lentamente como quiero.
Así que para ciertos estudiantes y ciertos tipos de información,
estos dos aspectos de los cómics, su naturaleza visual y su permanencia,
los hacen una increíble y poderosa herramienta educativa.
Cuando estaba enseñando Álgebra 2,
también estaba trabajando en mi maestría en Educación en Cal State East Bay.
Y estaba tan intrigado con esta experiencia en mis lecciones
que decidí enfocar el proyecto final de mi maestría en cómics.
Quería descubrir la razón por la que los educadores estadounidenses
han sido tan históricamente reacios a usar los libros de cómics en sus clases.
Esto es lo que descubrí.
Los cómics se publicaron de forma masiva en la década de los 40s,
con millones de copias vendidas cada mes,
y los educadores lo notaron.
Muchos profesores innovadores comenzaron a traer cómics a sus clases
para experimentar.
En 1944, el "Diario de Sociología Educativa"
dedicó una edición entera a este tema.
Las cosas parecían estar progresando.
Los profesores comenzaban a darse cuenta de esto.
Pero entonces aparece este señor.
Este es el Dr. Fredric Wertham, un psicólogo infantil
que en 1954 escribió un libro llamado "La seducción de los inocentes",
donde argumenta que los cómics causan delincuencia juvenil.
(Risas)
Estaba equivocado.
El Dr. Wertham era un señor muy decente.
La mayor parte de su carrera trabajó con delincuentes juveniles,
y en su trabajo notó que la mayoría de sus clientes leían cómics,
pero lo que el Dr. Wertham no notó era que en la década de los 40s y los 50s,
casi todo los niños en EE. UU. leían libros de cómics.
El Dr. Wertham hace un trabajo dudoso en probar su caso,
pero su libro sí inspiró al Senado de EE. UU.
a llevar a cabo una serie de audiencias
para ver si, en efecto, los cómics causaban delincuencia juvenil.
Estas audiencias duraron casi dos meses.
Terminaron de forma inconclusa, pero no sin antes hacer un tremendo daño
a la reputación de los libros de cómics a los ojos del público estadounidense.
Después de esto, educadores estadounidenses respetables
dieron un paso atrás, y los mantuvieron alejados por décadas.
No fue sino hasta la década de los 70s
que unos pocos valientes los comenzaron a utilizar nuevamente.
Y realmente no fue hasta hace poco,
quizás en la última década,
que los cómics han tenido una mayor aceptación
entre los educadores estadounidenses.
Los libros de cómics y las novelas gráficas
finalmente se están abriendo paso dentro de las aulas estadounidenses,
incluso en Bishop O'Dowd, donde yo enseñaba.
El Sr. Smith, uno de mis excolegas,
usa el libro de Scott McCloud, "Entendiendo los cómics",
en su clase de literatura y cine, porque ese libro les da a los estudiantes
el lenguaje para discutir la relación entre las palabras y las imágenes.
El Sr. Burns asigna un ensayo de cómics a sus estudiantes cada año.
Al pedirle a sus estudiantes que escriban una novela en prosa usando imágenes,
lo que les pide es que piensen profundamente
no solo en la historia,
sino también en cómo la historia está siendo contada.
Y la Sra. Murrock usa mi libro "Chino nacido en EE. UU."
con sus estudiantes de Inglés 1.
Para ella, las novelas gráficas
son una gran forma de alcanzar un estándar de núcleo común.
El estándar dice que los estudiantes
son capaces de analizar cómo los elementos contribuyen visualmente
al significado, el tono y la belleza del texto.
En la biblioteca, la Sra. Counts ha amasado
una impresionante colección de novelas gráficas para Bishop O'Dowd.
La Sra. Counts y todos sus colegas bibliotecarios
han estado realmente al frente de la defensa de los cómics
desde los inicios de los 80s,
cuando un artículo sobre bibliotecas escolares
mencionó que la mera presencia de novelas gráficas en la biblioteca
incrementaba su uso en un 80 %
y aumentaba la circulación de otro tipo de textos en un 30 %.
Inspirados por este interés renovado de los educadores estadounidenses,
los caricaturistas en EE. UU. producen ahora más que nunca,
contenido educativo explícito para lectores menores de 12 años.
Mucho de esto va dirigido a las clases de idiomas,
pero cada vez más los cómics y las novelas gráficas
están comenzando a entrar en los temas de matemáticas y ciencias.
Los cómics sobre ciencias, tecnologías, ingeniería y matemáticas
son un territorio desconocido listo para ser explorado.
Finalmente, EE. UU. está despertando al hecho
de que los libros de cómics no causan delincuencia juvenil.
(Risas)
Que realmente pertenecen al conjunto de herramientas de cada educador.
No hay una buena razón
para mantener a los cómics y las novelas gráficas
fuera de la educación a menores de 12 años.
Enseñan visualmente,
les dan a nuestros estudiantes ese control remoto.
El potencial educativo está allí,
esperando a ser aprovechado por gente creativa como Uds.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)